alle habe sogar herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen minecraft video
ich habe mir gedacht da ich schon lange
keine 2 vorgestellt habe stelle ich euch
zuvor allerdings ja das war kluge
aussage allerdings bin ich ja heute
nicht alleine sondern zusammen
das ist dass sie den könnt ihr dann eure
welt packen und dann habt ihr die
gleiche wert wie wir
und der ist richtig dass wir das was du
hier als erstes entdeckt hat diesen
erstmal eine unter wo bist du da bist du
ja wir haben eine unglaubliche
landschaft wir weder schon wir haben
hier überall so kranke sand formationen
wir haben hier vorne irgendso
schwebenden scheiß rumfliegen ja jetzt
auch schweben das hier oben noch mehr
schwebender scheiß egal wie hoch ist das
beste kraft hier das ist junge was ist
denn das man hier oben haben wir so eine
art savannen entspreche so ein bisschen
aufgebaut und dann kann man rein
theoretisch halt immer einfach hin
laufen und damit sind lukas in der luft
dann bist du einfach auf über 250
tatsächlich über die komplette welt
darüber gucken dann macht ihr sohn
grasboden hin junge wie krank ist das
denn aber stichwort dort ich habe auch
was entdeckt gerade eben als ich mal
kurz zum geflogen bin kommen wir jetzt
einfach ein feld in dieser höhe
das sind die 100 wenn ihr nichts gebaut
die krassesten
zudem könnte das ist okay okay sagt er
sagt er will dass ich ihn schubst
so kann ein junge
hier das ist ein gebäude das ist ein
gebäude das ist gebäude hier auch eins
das ist gebäude das ist die gebäude hier
auch eins das ist gebäude das ist über
gebäude da oben ist einfach so was habe
ich noch nie gesehen fällt im berg drin
das ist gebäude was für ein trost dass
ich sehr kurz vor der tür aber sand ich
will auch mal das ist ohne dass das
ganze dorf was ich jemals gesehen habe
kein scheiß ich drüben steht das feld
junge wie crazy ist das denn einfach so
jetzt sind wir hier gerade bei diesen
koordinaten hier angekommen
ja hier unten einer das trägt den namen
bistum fest
ich glaube ich nicht befreit haben wir
ja hier ist manchmal so übelsten ganz
schnell wieder bei der bibliothek
was ist denn das man als ob hier
nirgendwo jetzt endlich mal dieses dings
ist diese laufen jetzt wirklich schon
seit zwei stunden rum
ich hab' ich hab's nach seiner
halbstunden mein gott ich hab's gefunden
wenn diesen koordinaten das ende da oben
oder sind sogar ganz simpel koordinaten
20 40 und minus 6 140 einfach nur hier
ist noch so ein dorf in den bergen
tvtv dich zu mir junge was ist das denn
wir haben gerade eigentlich noch von
wüsten tempel rausgesucht den sie auch
noch geben soll
aber wir sind einfach wieder auf dem
dorf gestoßen die können auch mal bei
dem dorfe theoretischen gucken was ist
hier in der schmiede gibt weil da haben
die auch mal so ein paar altar wieder
nur solange wir sie wieder soviel kraft
viele dachgärten so 1234 felder vor
allem guck mal hier
das ist einfach komplett eben von unten
drunter hier ist wieder scheiße in der
luft die man sie auch selbst die scheiße
hat scheiße in der luft
die kletterer ist von hier aus
hier haben wir auch wieder so übelste
reims tore 3
ich bestellte pizza ganz schillig hier
vorne einfach noch ein dorf gefunden
brachte das ist bei diesen koordinaten
da jetzt bei diesen koordinaten hier
haben wir jetzt auch noch mal einen
wüsten tempel hier gefunden wo wir jetzt
auch mal ganz groß reingehen werden denn
ich möchte mal unbedingt sehen wir also
hier ist doch eigentlich ein echter nur
schwachsinn drin aber nicht wegnehmen
kann nichts passieren
bist du behindert ja gut freunde das war
jetzt jedoch den wüsten taylor ist jetzt
auch nicht so geile sachen und mal die
landschaft von diesem ziel ist einfach
wow wow wow wow das der lage wasserfall
und hier drüben ist doch ein wasserfall
die landschaft ist einfach echt grad
also findet ihn zieht in der
beschreibung zeigt dass auf jeden fall
mal auswerten erst gedacht 30 in dieser
form zu schneiden allerdings bin ich
jetzt in der 138 minuten und muss das
jetzt immer noch unter karten auf eine
annehmbare länger deswegen habe ich
gedacht wir zeigen euch heute einfach
nur einzieht und wenn ihr wollt dass wir
euch eventuell nochmal walten zeigen
dann was soll ich machen wenn ihr euch
fragt wer war denn dieser andere geile
sau dann verlinke ihr euch oder ich zeig
euch mal ganz gezielt auch schon was er
so macht
ok ja doch diesen speed bilder der
startnummer wenn euch das gefallen hat
dann kurze beschreibung vorbei da ist er
bestimmt auch irgendwo verlinkt und dann
sehen wir uns vielleicht bald in einem
anderen ceo wie da ich lass das letzte
wort sein wort